where is Richard Simmons that question
has been at the center of the podcast
missing Richard Simmons which aired its
last episode on Monday this is what I
think could be true something happened
to Richard Simmons in early 2014 and so
he retreated the fitness gurus longtime
manager Michael Catalano tells ET in an
exclusive statement that the podcast is
doing more harm than good quote the
podcast has not revealed one bit of new
information and it has given voice to
unreliable sources it's not only full of
fake news it's full of old news still
host Dan Tversky insists the podcast is
a way to help Richard by getting a
better understanding of why he left the
spotlight in the first place the longer
you stay in isolation the world goes on
without you and maybe for Richard that
means freedom Simmons rep says the star
is aware of the podcast but does not
support it richard has been seriously
harmed by those looking to make a name
for themselves or worse looking to cash
in
[Music]
you